all right
um good evening and welcome to this
meeting of the planning committee and
welcome to to those watching online
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door to my right or
opposite the lifts in the foyer through
the door at the back please do not use
the lifts please assemble in Hawley
Square on the green officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no I would advise that speakers using
the microphones are picked up by cameras
recording the meeting members of the
public in the public Gallery behind the
speakers in the middle there may be
picked up by those cameras and have
their image captured any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting
which everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress
okay
um I have the following members who wish
to speak under Council procedure rule
20.1 item 5c councilor Whitehead
are there any other mem are there any
other members who wish to speak under
Council procedure rule 20.1
uh the following applications have been
reserved for public speaking item 5c
British Heart Foundation item 5e crumps
farm and item 5f crumps Farm Stuart Lane
South birchington
agenda item number one I have apologies
from councilor Boyd substituted by
councilor Huxley apologies from
councilor Wings substituted by councilor
Mons
apologies from councilor ratigan
substituted by councilor towning and
apologies from councilor Dennis no
substitute
agenda item two are there any
Declarations of Interest
sorry any other apologies I've just been
reminded I think everyone's here no are
there any Declarations of Interest
no thank you
um agenda item three do members agree
that the minutes of the planning
committee held on the 16th of August be
approved as a correct record do I have a
proposal please
councilor Alban and do I have a
secondary councilor bayford
thank you we have a point of information
and I'm going to hand over oh does
everyone agree thank you
thank you
uh point of information I'm going to
hand over to the planning applications
manager who will update members on
agenda item 5A
thank you chair um just a brief update
on a01 which is land north of Telegraph
Hill just to correct a administrative
error in condition 8 which relates to
vehicle loading and unloading the
reference should be zero zero two
revision B rather than revision a so the
rest of the conditions include the
correct revision numbers but just to
confirm that that's an updated revision
number thank you
thank you a gender item four back to the
planning applications manager who will
now speak on this application
thank you chair
um so this is a gender item to decide on
the council's position in relation to an
appeal against the non-determination of
a household or planning application at
54 Stone Road
so previously an application was made
for a series of two-story extensions and
which was heard at April's planning
committee meeting a motion to approve
the application with officer
recommendation was voted down and a
motion was then passed to visit the site
before the site visit the applicant
appealed the um the non-determination of
the application which means now that the
decision is going to be made by the
planning inspectors
now the item is before members to
basically determine whether members
would would have if they still had the
power to determine the application
whether they would Grant the application
or whether or not they would refuse the
application so that the council can
respond to the appeal because that
appeal has now started so I'm going to
run through the application because I
appreciate that some members weren't on
the committee at that point so be the
normal presentation and then and then
the debate after that so the site is
outlined in red the main issues for this
application are the impact on the
character appearance the area and the
impact on neighboring properties
so the site is in the center of this
aerial image and we'll just have a
little look here so it's between
two sort of two stories of Two and a
Half story on the on the left hand side
there so it's the Bungalow that's in the
center of the image there just to look
at these are the original images that
were presented to members previously
um so this is the The Bungalow in
question that's proposed to be extended
on the left hand side you've got 56 a
and on the right hand side you've got 52
a
so this is 52a you can see sort of
behind the Hedge there and then moving
to the left you can see some
developments that have occurred over the
past few years
um 56a was a new build
building in the last probably about the
last 10 years in total in terms of the
history that goes back this is an image
from Google just showing the um sort of
roof forms of all the dwellings together
This Is A View From the rear of the
Bungalow so you can see on now on the
left hand side you've got 52a on the
right hand side you've got 56a
so this is looking towards 56a so you
can see the relationship between the two
properties
and then the other side so you've got
some landscaping that's there but you
can see
um the the neighboring property behind
that
and then this is just a view straight
down the garden from the rear of the
existing property
so this is the existing block plan uh
showing the relationship between 52a and
56a and the site of 54. so at the moment
you've got the Dormer window so Chalet
Bungalow Arrangement and then you've got
the single story flat roof extension at
the back
what's being proposed is effectively to
build a I suppose a roof extension but
creating a first floor within a Gable
which runs
um you know front of the Gable at the
front and the Gable at the back with a
sort of up down roof to side to side
with first floor accommodation it does
also extend to the rear from the
previous footprint of the building so
you can see there's the footprint as
what it what it is currently and then
there will be an extension to the rear
which we'll look at in a second
so this is the existing front elevation
um that we saw in the photos
and what's being proposed is to keep the
the general footprint in terms of the
width of the property but obviously
putting uh increase in the height of the
eaves and then putting accommodation
within the sort of the roof form that's
created to create a sort of full first
floor so the eaves are increasing by
approximately sort of 0.9 of a meter so
almost a meter they're going up on the
side so if you look at the eaves here
that's basically increasing above the
existing Eaves
and we'll look at that on the side
elevations for the relevance to the
neighbors
so then we're going to look at the
elevation which faces 56a on the the
left hand side of the properties you
look at it in this image
so
currently you can see that it's made up
from a single story sort of side garage
and then you've got existing Bungalow
you'll just noted from the photos the
step down that occurs in terms of the
land levels so what's being proposed
here is that the eaves come up to this
level and then it pitches away with that
pitched roof so the roof form that you
can see here which obviously on the
elevation looks quite large is the
pitching away roof so the main bulk and
mass adjacent to the neighbor is up to
the eaves height and that's where
there's an extension at the rear here as
well as the increase in 900 mil above
what it currently is in terms of the
eaves
and then in terms of the relationship
with the neighboring property at number
52 a
so this is the existing elevation that
faces number 52a
seeks the number of openings in that
side facing the the neighbor
and then what's being proposed again is
an extension that comes out about it's
about 2.9 in terms of the bolts about
three meters with the overhang
approximately and then again that
increase in Eaves in comparison to the
existing now
what's previously not been provided and
was one of the issues in terms of the
members raised about a site visit is
just showing the relationship with the
name and property at number 52 a because
there is obviously an extension which
extends back further than the existing
relationship so you can see those
windows that were on the side of the
ocean of the existing Bungalow there you
can see the existing Eaves at this point
here with the fascia where the mouse
pointer is so the that will be increased
in height into thieves it's not coming
any closer in the sense of that's still
going to be the side wall but that Eaves
height is going up so there is an
additional sort of Band of
um of of mass above the existing Eaves
level and then there is that extension
out
um further
so you've got on the rear elevation
you've got
um at the ground floor you've got
habitable room room window here in terms
of the uh the serving the kitchen to the
property next door
we've also got is a distance between the
side of number 52a which is on the left
of the image and the site are number 54.
so the distance between those two
um those two sort of properties is
um so I've got it down here
um no I did have it down here
um oh it's sorry it's on the plan
oh
foreign
seven meters approximately between the
side elevation of number 50
52a and number 54.
um and because of that um it's obviously
quite a notable distance usually you're
sort of one meter one side one meter
another side as well as the fact that
there is obviously an existing
um I suppose interrelationship in terms
of the mass that we don't consider the
increase in the height of the eaves and
the additional built form would be
significantly harmful to the neighbor
obviously this is the proposed site plan
so you can see in terms of the window
isn't obviously for for the number 52a
it's not directly on the side wall of
the property it's obviously set in that
we saw from the image so you can see
that the 45 degree line has been shown
on this plan to indicate that there is
no not in you know in our view certainly
a sense of enclosure created that would
cause a significant adverse impact on
either the patio area or indeed
habitable room windows 2 number 52a
so in terms of the rear elevation
another of the concerns that was raised
in the discussion in April
was about the inclusion of a balcony now
to confirm and this is obviously at the
rear um this balcony faces down the
garden and one of the issues that was
raised is just to confirm that this
balcony does not protrude out from that
rear Gable it's it's an inset uh balcony
so if we look at I'm just going to go
through these ground floor plans to then
get to the first floor plan
so this is the balcony itself the walls
are for effectively the roof
um is effectively overhangs where the
balconies so the balcony views are
channeled down the garden you cannot
turn to the right or turn to the left
when you're standing on the balcony and
see directly into the neighbor's uh
property either side
so yeah just to confirm that's why it
obviously it looks on the elevation as
if there's obviously a balcony but it
doesn't protrude out from the rear of
the property
um so in terms of other considerations
um we have
obviously a change in the appearance of
the dwelling on the street scene it's
not considered given that there are
two-story properties along Stone Road
there is considered to be adequate space
either side of the the property from
from the design there was a previous
approval on the site which
I've just clicked through to that so
previously it was approved
um last year to provide an extension
which predominantly had the mass in the
middle of the site and obviously in this
instance
um this the side element facing number
52a wasn't extending as far back as this
this proposal so this was found to be
acceptable and this is the site plan of
what was approved previously
um one of the other issues that didn't
come up that I think be useful just to
clarify is there were some concerns
raised about the boundary wall
um and the sort of harm potentially to
immunity this is a an image from Google
from a few years ago which
um where there previously was a um a
flint wall down as the side side wall
that ran down the property which has
been which was demolished and then
replaced by a block wall which I think
you can see on
this image here there is a condition
which was proposed on the application
when it was put to members for approval
which would basically require the
retention of of the wall at the front
however it's just really important to
note that no planning permission is
needed to demolish walls of
um you know of the height of of one
meter or indeed two meters we're not in
a conservation area so it doesn't it
doesn't constitute development under the
planning act so
um you know the work that's occurred to
demolish the barrier to the side is is
perfectly lawful
um but in terms of obviously what we're
trying to retain and the applicant has
agreed to retaining the the wall at the
front
um which you know I do think obviously
residents consider is quite important
um so in terms of
in terms of the considerations then we
do consider there isn't harm to the to
neighboring properties uh certainly not
significant harm and the the design is
considered to be acceptable so the
materials are to be is white clad
effectively the um the the Gable end
there is obviously a different palette
of colors in the area as well as a
different palette of material so we
don't think there's harm on the
character and appearance of the area
so overall officers recommend that
members agree that permission would have
been granted subject to the conditions
in Annex one
um and therefore no objection would be
raised to the appeal for
non-determination
thank you I moved at the office of no
I've been too far yeah I move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted with
the vice chair please second
Ed
thank you councilor bayford
thank you chair
um I called this in and also asked for
the site visit
In fairness to uh residents who
questioned the measurements
of the proposed Construction
and um felt it it would be fair to
everybody for us to go and have a look
unfortunately the site visit doesn't
happen but the presentation this evening
to me has
um settled a lot of the issues that were
raised and I feel now that there is
little reason to refuse this thank you
councilor Auburn
thank you chair
um I was happy with this in April and
I'm happy with it I'm happy with it now
and I'm happy to support the officer's
recommendation in 3.1 in a report thank
you
councilor Keane
thank you chair just a question it was
probably covered in April but I can't
remember between 52a and this house the
windows at the side on the upper level I
can see there's one is that opaque is
there any windows on 52a
so on the actual proposal itself there
aren't proposed to be any uh they're
supposed to be velox Windows if I can
actually find
there we go so you've got you've got
Velux windows they're set
um in line with the property X door so
there's no consideration that it's not
considered there would be any harmful
overlooking you've obviously got at the
moment there is an interrelationship
between those ground floor windows that
obviously they are they're actually
reducing a ground floor and because of
the way the boundary treatments are as
you saw from the photo there is a bit of
overlooking at the moment frankly which
would arguably be improved by you know
removing the windows in the proposal but
we do think overall that relationship is
is acceptable as proposed
councilor Garner
thank you yeah when when we discuss this
um in April uh those of us who are here
we we did Express a number of us
expressed a number of concerns uh to
such an extent that we did need we did
feel that a site visit was preferable
before making a decision
um and I from what I've heard I still
believe that a site visit
would be required before I would be able
to confidently make a decision so My
Views haven't changed I mean it's been
taken out of our hands by the sound of
it
um but I'm I'm still of that opinion
unfortunately a site visit is not an
option anymore
um do I have any other speakers
counselor Mata face well well
um there's sort of been some of the
speaking I made some notes it's no
higher than it will be no higher or
larger than either of the buildings on
either 52a or 56 it's currently set back
it's just going to bring it into a line
it's not coming any closer to either of
the properties you've said the balcony
Shield is so people won't be sitting
there looking in the next door garden
and you said that the boundary wall is
being retained or it doesn't your plan
and permission so it's although
obviously I wasn't here in April I
personally can't see any objection to
what is up there and I would support
approval
thank you
um in that case we will now put the
motion for the officer's recommendation
for approval to the vote can I have all
those in favor please
any against
any abstentions
thank you
so the motion is carried thank you
the next item to first state that what
could Ian let me explain what happens
next please
yes certainly
um so we have to submit an appeal
statement
um following the questionnaire being
submitted on the appeal and what we will
be stating in that is that the council
raises no objection for the
non-determination appeal we will put
forward the conditions which were
originally recommended to members
um and and basically state that we would
have granted planning permission and the
the inspector will still consider the
you know still make a decision so they
still consider the merits the case and
obviously we have forwarded all
correspondence from you know people that
have written in so the inspector will
still make their own decision but we
will state that we would have granted
permission for it
[Music]
thank you
um so any site visits will take place
for committee members on the morning of
Friday the 6th of October if you can
just make a note of that for now please
and
um moving on to agenda item 5c this is
uh the British Heart Foundation in High
Street Margate
first speaking in favor of this
application is Mr Peter monley you have
three minutes
thanks champ
um we're from July committee that this
was why the scheme is before you uh now
I wanted to take a little time to lay
some nervousness that I detected at that
July meeting about the scheme in our
approach
um a fairly unique site building
and application strategy there are some
16 specific conditions and requirements
that need to be met from a part 20 prior
approval
application of this nature these relate
to location Heights use and age of the
building
um I would have thought it's highly
unlikely that there would be many
similar circumstances particularly in
Margate Town Center
um due to its General streetscape and
the number of historic buildings where
um uh similar applications could be
brought forward the fact that this
application is the first one before
Committee in three years since the the
guidance or since the regs were
introduced also tells its own story and
we started this process in 21 with some
useful dialogue in pre-application when
our two-step application approach was
supported by officers I'm sure you've
all carefully read the comprehensive
report by the case officer and I just
wanted to emphasize a few key issues
it's not a planning matter but the
British Heart Foundation lease ends this
year I'm not aware they wanted to extend
this
and they did an object to either the
previous application or this one and
there were a total of six
representations with one being in
support a number of the representative
the Reps focused on the suitability of
residential in town centers and displays
in retail no retail will be displaced as
a result of this application and the
mppf is clear it says residential
development often plays an important
role in ensuring the Vitality of centers
um as indicated earlier the scheme
complies with all of the quite stringent
prior approval conditions and
requirements we agree in terms of
designing an appearance that the scheme
would enhance the host building and
streetscape with its contemporary
approach and highly and high quality
materials importantly it would integrate
with the scheme below please note the
scheme has been amended with the Upper
Floor moved back and Dormers removed to
lessen visual impact high standard of
occupy occupier immunity is proposed
flats are spacious light and dual aspect
private immunity is provided the sizes
in town center where there is often
residential accommodation above ground
floor commercial uses we would concur
with the assessment that there'd be no
or inconsequential impacts on Neighbors
in terms of privacy Outlook daylight
sunlight
it's a highly sustainable site close to
amenities in public transport their
Highway controls to front and rear my
clients have happy to greet all
conditions proposed including the CMP
and also to the mitigation that measures
set forward to reduce impact on nearby
natural habitats in conclusion I
therefore ask that members resolve to
Grand prior approval thank you chair
thank you speaking against the
application is Mr Colin Mitchell you
have three minutes
hello there um yes um first first matter
basically we've spoken to the British
heart foundation and they have just
renewed a five-year lease
um so are they every intention of
staying in Margate and if it gets
approved sorry can I just momentarily
can you turn your microphone off please
thank you
yeah they've got every intention of
staying in Margate and if they if this
gets approved then obviously they'll be
out because there's nowhere else with
the size of the building for them to
continue with basically
um
let's start have a thing
right basically we own property across
the road and we strongly a jet to the
proposal because the height of the
proposed extension will be out of
proportion and ugly the visual impact is
not acceptable in keeping with the
Victorian buildings within the adjacent
Terrace and High Street area the
development will be 3.5 meters higher
than the other Terrace
um
this will block our natural light into
the property and others adjacent in High
Street and we overlooked for residential
residence residents and Shoppers the
loss of privacy has the front of my home
will be directly overlooked by 18
windows from nine different dwellings
basically and it's only eight meters
from the front of our building
um the density of the dwellings in the
proposed development 10 dwellings in a
close proximity there's existing issues
with foul drainage in the area the
addition of 10 new buildings will put
strain on this system
the noise and disturbance from tempos
dwellings in close proximity
um
access for new residents Herbert Place
rear of the building where the exit is
going to be is no parking at any time no
unloading at any time there's nowhere at
the rear that anyone can pull up a
vehicle or unload it basically and
basically it's adopted area for all the
fast food delivery drivers from
McDonald's and everything else
and they've been ousted and they just go
up the High Street instead so it's
already congested and yeah I counted 16
cars parked up the High Street tonight
there's no traffic wardens it's a danger
to pedestrians more residents
chain 10 new Flats they've got to have
some Vehicles somewhere
probably Park them in High Street
because you've got less chance of
getting a ticket there than anywhere
else
um
um and I've got a quote from planet
local plan
policy qd03
living conditions all new developments
should be compatible with neighborhood
buildings and spaces and not lead to
unacceptable living conditions through
overlooking noise of vibration light
pollution overshadowing loss of natural
light or sense of enclosure
we have the size and layout with
sufficient usable space to facilitate to
comfortable living conditions and meet
the set out meet the standards set out
in qd03 residents of Redmond should
include the vision of private or shared
external amenities space play Space
where possible it backs onto a car park
that's great isn't it
you set me down
sorry yes thank you speaking under
Council rule 20.1 councilor Helen
Whitehead
thank you chair
the heart of development is far more
than the legalities of development
we know this as councilors we come
across it frequently in that there are
many times that Central planning
legislation conflicts with what we
believe to be a positive outcome and I
know and recognize this problem
but I also know the difficulties that my
ward faces and especially our High
Street which means that the nature of
Prior approval requires discussion
good development is a matter of balance
not simply what is allowed it requires
listening to the community around you
and addressing their concerns
progress has been made on this in terms
of considering the impact of the upper
windows in trying to reduce the impact
of overlooking but the fact remains that
a two-story extension will mean that the
development is out of keeping for the
local area blocks light and changes its
character
we are advised to principally consider
nppf requirements in relation to this
application
some of the considerations relevant here
are as follows
firstly we need to be certain that the
development will function well and will
add to the overall quality of the area
as everyone here will know I consider
housing an absolute priority but I am
also very much concerned with the nature
of Housing and in this case I do not
believe that a two-story extension where
residents overlooked by the car park and
businesses will lose lives to be an
additioning quality or a development
that will function well as it currently
stands from a design perspective
secondly a development should be
visually attractive I believe that this
design has the potential to be
attractive but to prepare your scale of
it and share a number of flats makes it
difficult to judge as visually
attractive in its current context
thirdly the development should be
sympathetic to local character and
history I do not believe that a
development of this size in a small High
Street with small and traditionally
arranged retail premises is sympathetic
to local character or history I see
Merit in the fundamentals of the
potential design put forward but again
the scale removes any sympathy for local
character in history and renders it
overwhelming
fourthly a development should establish
or maintain a strong sense of Place
Margate High Street is distinct with a
mix of small and established retail
premises and lower density residential
and accommodation on typically one or
two other floors it is again the scale
of this development that ensures that it
is undermining a distinct sense of place
as the combination of newer design
features and the visual impact of four
floors does not support the existing
sense of place
finally it should help to create places
that are safe inclusive and accessible
this is not a development that can
provide parking or the accessibility and
safety of doorstep parking it cannot be
described as accessible or inclusive
I know the limitations we are faced with
here in terms of central permissions but
I ask that the committee consider how
the design and construction of this
development can take into consideration
resident needs and concerns
dialogue between this committee the
developer and residence is vital to
consider the viability of what could be
a very good design because although we
may not always agree we can agree that
we should all be heard thank you
thank you I'll now hand over to the
planning applications manager to outline
the report no
you instead thank you
thank you chair this is the application
site in red here so we have Margate High
Street to the left Herbert place to the
rear um we've got the multi-story car
park in this location here
and this is an aerial view of the site
so it's this building in the center here
so it's a you can see it's a large
building currently takes up the the
whole site it's a company a two-story
building
and this is another view just so you can
see
um the roofscape of uh the the street so
you can see that
um this is two-story off to the
left-hand side there's a few other
two-story buildings but you can see to
the right they rise to three stories and
there's taller buildings on the right
hand side of this aerial view so the
proposal is for an additional two floors
above this building
so this is a view from street level
looking at the building
um so again you can see it's a different
style building to other properties in
the street so whilst the majority of
buildings are quite uh Victorian in
their Design This is actually quite a
different style with the concrete to the
front and setback windows and then
there's a wide shot front at the bottom
so I'll just remind members later on of
the um proposal that was approved in
July's committee which was to change the
shop front and to provide alterations at
this first floor level
so again they should do some further
photos of the building
and again you could just see again the
the difference in design of the existing
building
it's the proposal that was previously
approved was to retain the commercial at
ground floor level with residential
above and this proposal is for further
residential above
um the existing first floor level so
again you can see the building in them
on the left-hand side here at street
view
and then this is the rear from Herbert
place so this is the existing building
here
and the proposal would be for The
Pedestrian access to the flats from this
rear access you can see there's existing
lighting
um so it's it's a sort of a safe access
for pedestrians
um and then this is a view here again
with the property in the distance on the
left here
and then it's just again further from
the other side so again the building is
in this location here
and again here so the proposal will be
for two floors
um above here but this this part here is
remains as it is and the two the two
additional floors are further back so
it's it's um it pop above the main part
of the building not this rear section
and then again just another view showing
the existing accesses into the site
and again here
so this is the existing um front
elevation
this was the previously approved front
um that members saw at July committee so
this approved
um the alterations to the shop fronts at
ground floor level but as I said it
remains as commercial use and it
approved alterations at first floor
level
um to the windows
um and that provided residential
accommodation
so um this this application is a prior
notification application
um there's been a few changes through
the application so this was the
originally submitted plan for this
application so it shows there's an
additional floor
um at second floor level and then above
that the accommodation is provided
within the roof
and you can see that the original
proposal was a mansard with
um Dorma projections in the front of
this
so just to provide a bit of information
on this type of application
um the applications come in as
um a prior approval application under
the general committee development order
um the general permitted development
order allows for two additional stories
to be provided
um on a terrorist building above a
retail unit and therefore this is
permitted development but it's only
permitted development subject to this
prior approval process being carried out
and through this prior approval process
we can consider a number of different
issues so the issues we can consider are
the impact on highway safety the impact
on the external appearance the impact on
light to the residential accommodation
being provided the impact on neighboring
living conditions so we can look at the
impact from potential overlooking and
light and outlook on neighbors and the
impact on the future occupies from noise
from any commercial unit so there are
the considerations and we have to
consider those under the MP if we can't
consider them under local plan policy
so um as I said this was the originally
submitted application
um we consulted neighbors and there were
concerns raised regarding the design and
regarding the um the two floors
as I said we can't actually object to
the principle of the two stories because
that is actually permitted development
all we can look at is the design and um
and the impacts on Neighbors from this
so we've looked at whether we can reduce
um the impact on neighbors by changing
the um the roof level as you can see in
terms of the actual additional second
floor being added the neighbor to the
right hand side is already three stories
so in terms of the actual ease level of
the building it actually does tie up
with the neighbor to the right hand side
so it'll be unreasonable to to suggest
that from a design point of view this
would be having a significant impact on
the character of the area because it is
similar to the scale of noble properties
so the main issue from from our point of
view and from seeing what the neighbors
raised as well is is the impact on roof
level so this was the originally
submitted plan
um this was the um the the 3D image
provided of the original submission so
you can see it was a mansard with the
projecting Dormers at roof level
um they then revised the application to
set the manside back
um which helped but we still felt there
were concerns because it still appeared
quite dominant in terms of the views you
would have of these um dongle windows to
the front and then the final amended
plan that is for members to consider
tonight is this proposal which is now
showing the Dormers removed and these
windows are now
um basically v-locks Windows really
flush with the mansard roof so this is
um just a image now showing that it's
from a slightly different angle but you
can see you don't now have the
projections of the Dormers at that level
and this is the view then you would get
from street level looking up of of the
additional second floor and then the top
floor set back
um this was the previously submitted
section plan so again you can see in
terms of the roof design so this was the
additional um second floor being
provided and then this was the mansod
um at roof level and this was the
Dormers within that front space and
that's how it's now been amended so you
can see the windows are now angled back
and in line with the mansard roof and
and set back from the front
um you can see then from this view as
well so the this is the so basically
this is two
the maisonettes and there's six um two
bed Mason that's been provided within
this space so a ground floor level
um or the bottom level of the Mason net
is the bedrooms and the top floor would
be the kitchens and the lounges and you
can see that there's a rear balcony area
to serve um each of the flats
then access would be from the rear here
and then again this area on the left
hand side was already approved through
the previous application and it provided
for a communal Garden at this level and
this application now provides for access
from that Garden into the Mason Nets
and then this is just another section
view so this is now taken from the
center of the building and it just again
shows the two additional floors and you
can see in relation to one of the
further buildings away so there are some
buildings that are taller than this
um that's probably around four or five
units away from this one
um and it does show that therefore in
terms of the scale it's it's not
completely out of character with What's
um in the street you can also see on
this section the neighboring properties
as well given the fact that neighbors
have raised concerns with the impact on
on light and Outlook and you can see the
distance to the neighboring properties
um
the additional floor will potentially
have some impact on Outlook but it's
quite a typical relationship that you
would see within the High Street so it's
difficult to object given the fact that
there are numerous other properties
along here that
um have that same relationship
um again with the additional top floor
that's and the Amendments that have now
happened this will reduce the impact on
the neighbors from this now setback
element at roof level and the windows
here given the fact that now no longer
Dormers and they're actually angled in
the roof will help to reduce overlooking
from this top level as well
so this is the existing rear elevation
this was the previously approved rear
renovation again members approved at
July committee so just some alterations
to that rear to introduce some new
windows and the access to the the units
and this is now the proposed rear
renovation so members are considering
these additional flaws and that you can
see at the top here
it's difficult from to see it from this
plan but these floors are set quite far
away I think again you saw it from here
that this is the location of these so
they don't come back as far as that rear
section they're set back in in line with
the the main building
so
um here so this is the rear view you can
see the the balconies provided and the
center of each of the the flats and each
of them are provided with privacy
screens on the sides there would be no
overlooking from these to the sides of
the properties
um and then so this this was just to
show you again that photo from the rear
so again this bit here is the bit that
it stays in this of the same scale and
then the two floors will be further back
so you you would see the top of it but
it wouldn't feel as dominant as it as it
gives the impression of in the elevation
plan
and then this is the proposed ground
floor plan again not really for
consideration other than the fact the
refuse storage area has been provided
for the units and to the rear here and
you can see the access to the units in
this in this location here with the
staircase but again the actual
um subdivision of the retail units was
approved with the previous application
um that was the existing first floor
plan and that was the proposed vessel
plan but again not really for
consideration because this was the
layout that members approved in July
with um the three Flats in this location
here and the flat to the rear again this
will be the staircase at the back that
would then continue up to the next two
floors and this is the location of the
cycle storage area that would be for the
additional Flats as well
and now this is the proposed um second
floor
so these are the bedrooms you've got a
bedroom at the rear and a bedroom at the
front with
um staircase in the center that would go
to the top floor and the bar for in that
location and then this is the top floor
with the lounge to the front and the
kitchen dining area to the rear with um
this balcony so again on this plan you
can see the side privacy screens between
each of the um balconies and also on the
ends to prevent any overlooking down to
neighboring properties
and then this is just the roof plan
showing um that mansard and then the
windows
so in terms of the considerations
through the prior notification
application
in terms of the impact on Neighbors
as mentioned it's not considered that
there would be significant overlooking
or loss of Outlook given the fact that
this is a typical relationship in the
street and whilst this is showing um the
height of some of the properties
the some some of the um this elevation
here shows that some of the other
properties are already fronting on to
um the existing building and actually
the additional floor would be level with
some of the roofs of the neighboring
properties opposite
um so I believe that section probably
shows this property here that's the
three stories
um so in terms of actual impact on
neighbors it's not considered that
there's a significant enough impact to
Warrant refusal on the impact on
neighboring living conditions
um in terms of the actual provision of
the of of accommodation within the units
themselves they all meet the space
standards they all have adequate light
um to the properties with Windows to the
front and rear serving each of the
habitable rooms
um there's adequate waste provision
provided on a waste storage area
provided at the ground floor along with
the cycle storage space
in terms of noise there wouldn't be any
issue regarding noise from commercial
units because the first floor level
would be residential so um there would
be it they wouldn't be adjacent to a
commercial use
in terms of parking the site's located
within the Town Center so it'll be
difficult to to argue that there's a
requirement for for parking provision if
we work a sitter in the local plan this
would be in an area where parking
wouldn't be required to be provided
because of it being in the Town Center
and they're also also is the the public
car park to the rear and the cycle
storage provided and given the fact it's
a sustainable location we couldn't
object to it on on Highway grounds
um
so that covers the majority of that
covers all of the issues that we could
consider through the prior notification
process so given these amendments to the
design
um it's considered that the external
appearance will fit in with
um what's already been approved at First
full level
um and the the ease level of neighboring
properties and now that this top floor
has been set back and therefore you
would have limited views of this element
it's considered that the external
appearance would also be acceptable so
it is recommended to be deferred for
approval subject to the submission of
the unnatural undertaking securing the
SBA contribution thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted with the vice
chair please second
Ed
thank you we will now go into the debate
but um could I just say I know that
there's a lot of strong feeling
um about this I cannot take any more
comments from anyone who is not an
officer or not a member of this actual
committee and just as a reminder and
thank you
um so do I have any anyone who wants to
speak councilor Alban
yes thank you chair
um
effectively we've got a fighter company
here uh in that uh we we don't really
have a choice thanks to our government
for changing the regulations
to allow this type of thing
to actually happen
um and it doesn't give us the amount of
control that that we should have in my
humble opinion
um that said because of fighter complete
the changes that have been made from
from the original
application
um drawings
is far better
so
as saying it's a fight accompli and I
will support the recommendation thank
you chair
thanks chair um so just just a couple of
points and one that I'm gonna have to
confer with the chair about in a second
which will make clear to everyone
um the
um
the the issue with regards to Prior
approval process
um is is that it does sort of give a
principal agreement to this type of
development it doesn't necessarily
exclude the consideration for example of
external appearance that specifically
mentioned
um I think that there is there's been
much dispute in case law and appeals
about whether or not you can consider
issues to do with scale when looking at
external appearance and it is considered
that it can be looked at to the extent
of which the immediate impact rather
than a sort of wider impact on for
example the street scene so I think that
whilst you know it does it does sort of
Point towards a principal agreement to
the idea of two stories going on proper
buildings it still does allow the
consideration of the external impact
obviously from the views of of officers
we consider that by virtue of the height
um of what's been shown and the
relationship with properties all the way
along we don't actually think that there
is harm to the character and we don't
think it looks overly dominant but it is
a point
um I just want to clarify something that
the officers just just outlined that
this is actually recommended for defer
and Delegate for approval now that isn't
actually what's written at the front of
your schedule but just to be absolutely
clear on the motion that's been moved
and then been seconded that is as the
officer stated it's to defer for
approval and this is for the unilateral
undertaking to secure the SBA
contribution just to be clear what's in
front of members to consider thank you
um did counselor bayford thank you
thank you chair
um
this is set at the top of the High
Street not not in the middle of it
um I feel that the conditions of the
prior application have been met
consider our adaptations have been made
to minimize the harm to neighbors and we
will
as a result of this if it's approved
um have a lot several more dwellings
which are so badly needed
um
frankly I I cannot see any real reason
to refuse this application
and I'm not sure that we would have
grounds to anyway thank you
councilor Kane
thank you chair
why why isn't there any pavement at the
back where the access is I would have
thought from highway safety for a
residential dwelling that would have
been necessary
just
[Music]
um so in terms of I mean obviously it's
it's not something that's been proposed
it's the limits the highway extend I
think directly up to the building
looking there's there's no space for it
and obviously
um in terms of at the moment there are a
different number of accesses that I
think most people know because of where
the car park is um and coming in there
it's quite a familiar sort of stretch
um you know it's not considered that
again it's not ideal in terms of
progester access there obviously it was
something that was looked at in the
application that members saw in July
which was increasing and creating Flats
there and again the highways view was
that because the lower level of
pedestrian movements that it wouldn't
result in a highway safety issue but
yeah I think that I think everyone
agreed to be better if there was a
pavement there but it's it's not been
proposed and nor is it a requirement
that we think we could justifiably again
refuse this on the ground so it doesn't
have one
thank you councilor Garner
thank you yeah there are a couple of
things a couple of points yeah I
remember when we we considered the the
previous plan application in July and
and approved it I think most of us were
in favor of it one of the things that
stuck out for me that I liked was uh
despite it being where it is there was
some Community amenity area
for the residents of the it was four
then three two bed and one one bed
um Flats to use on the roof
um I just want some clarification really
because
the now there's an extra six Flats it's
the community amenity area still the
same size I.E on the
would it be on the first floor or out
the back of the first floor so there's
it's going to be a
see if they want to use it it's going to
be a bit much more crowded amenity
Community amenity area
the other thing I wanted to just clarify
um so we've given approval for four
units
and there's now going to be another six
making ten
ten units in here
um if this was a planning application
for 10 units then there would be a
requirement for
three of them to be affordable wouldn't
they
so is there is there
is should we be considering
um making three of these affordable
units
thank you thank you I'll come back on
the affordable point it's 11 units than
there needs to be before you start look
at 30
um but yeah it's it's so it it doesn't
trigger um in terms of that cumulative
and we do look at that as a cumulative
point it is trickier with his prior
approval but it doesn't it doesn't
trigger in this instance and again the
local plan doesn't really apply in the
sense of this is from in the general
permitted development order so it defers
to the mppf
um I don't know whether it's going to
come around the communal area
um
it's privately approved as a communal
space so it it's still there I mean it's
not annotated communal space anymore
um but it is still there but it would
also be the area that the units would be
accessed from with this walkway being
created to um the doorways here so
um
yeah it still exists but it would be
small loan it would be serving um a
greater number of units but each of
these do have the the balconies as well
so in theory they might well be using
those unless using these maybe but yeah
the space is still there is
um and you can see that there's some
Landscaping that wraps around the edge
of of that space
so so in effect
the six the six new ones on the top have
gained a balcony and or they're they're
getting a balcony and they're gaining
access via the communal space which was
a benefit for the four or five previous
which is now a bit less of a benefit for
those five
that wasn't one of the what you you
mentioned you listed a number of things
that we could consider which was to do
with neighbors and Highway Safety but
the actual people who are going to live
there isn't something that we can
consider
no the only consideration for the future
occupiers is to make sure that the flats
are large enough and that they have
enough light
um into the units but there's not a
requirement for any Dorset play space
for those units
counselor Mata face thank you chair
actually both cancer gone and Council
King took two of my points I was going
to raise but it one of the objections
and gentleness explainers about zero
parking unloading in her place which is
not that uncommon in times nowadays but
just a simple question the shops that
are there where do they unload
or don't do they just ignore the no one
loading
um thank you chair the British Heart
Foundation has a door at the back at the
moment so um in terms of in terms of
where you know it's at the front or the
back obviously I think again everyone
knows the High Street is used in terms
of loading at the front
um again it's obviously the previous
application has looked at the issue of
subdividing those units already
um but again there's not a greater
conflict between vehicular movements and
pedestrian movements as a result of this
proposal in comparison to the existing
relationships
any other questions or comments
um in that case we will now put the
motion for the officer's recommendation
for deferral and delegate Delegate for
approval those in favor
and those against
thank you
were there any absentions
so the motion is carried for deferral
and delegate thank you
um next item on the agenda is crumps
Farm
um speaking in favor of this application
is Mr George essdale
you have three minutes
thoughts
um I'm speaking purely about the list of
building application not the planning
application my colleague Susanna will
deal with planning matters in a minute
um
our design approach with historic
building sites is always to understand
the significance of the buildings
the development of the site over time
we've done a full assessment of the site
along with our colleagues at Country
archaeological Trust
to inform our significance-led approach
on the application
on the site we have one eight Bay listed
Barn one five a unlisted Barn however we
have taken
a
a design approach that has is in tune
with list of building applications with
this fight Bay Barn so we've treated it
like a list of building
in terms of its subdivision and its
external treatment we've also got a
cottage that we're using and a Dutch
Barn that we seek to use as well so the
proposal if approved will show a very
good development of the sites uh
at the plan form development over the
course of time
the buildings are seriously at risk and
they need a new use they don't have a
use and are in
quite a perilous state of disrepair
and we've done a full assessment we've
worked with Conti sever to
understand what those costs mean in
terms of the future and the the amount
of development that we need just to sort
of break even on the site which amounts
to what our proposed Liz this is the
bare minimum level of development that
we can get away with on the site
from a sustainability point of view the
ReUse of existing buildings is key to
our climate crisis at the moment it's
not high highly discussed but existing
building Fabrics should be saved and
conserved and it's embodied carbon
that's already been spent hundreds of
years ago in this case will stay where
it is and we will carry on using it
rather than you know letting the
buildings fall down and go to waste
so a couple of very simple key design
benefits as well to the proposals the
removal of unsympathetic and modern
buildings from the site and improving
the setting of historic buildings
generally and in The Wider landscape
setting
the replacement of inappropriate
materials that have been used over time
on site to the list of buildings and the
unlisted buildings which will
proposing to save
and we will be using traditional local
materials that will sit properly in the
landscape
and that's all I wouldn't say thank you
very much
thank you speaking on behalf of Saint
Nicholas at Wade with SAR Parish Council
councilor Dave Davis
um May I defer to the next
on the planning application as opposed
to enlisted building
yes certainly thank you
in which case I will hand over to the
principal planning officer for the
presentation please
thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red
so this is crumps Farm there is a land
also in the ownership of the applicant
which you can see extends
um past the site and is outlined in blue
so as it's been mentioned this is the
application for the listed building
consent and the next one is for the
planning application so we'll talk about
things like highways and things in that
application so this is concentrating on
the impact of the development or excuse
me on the listed buildings and the
curtinigalistic buildings
so this is an aerial view of the site so
it it sits in this location here
and essentially there is as has been
mentioned one actual listed building
which is which is a freshing balm which
is listed in its own right which is
grade two listed there are also the
unlisted Barn that's been mentioned
since in this location here we have a
pair of well a building that was I think
one building at one time but it's now a
pair of cottages
the Dutch Barn that's been mentioned in
this location here and there's some
historic um single-story buildings in
this location here there are some other
buildings you'll see
um here and here and some store
buildings sort of in the main part of
the site that are not historic but I
will touch on the building so they go
around so we're going to start with the
actual listed building itself
so here are some pictures of it so you
can see
it's had a bit of alteration over its
time
but it is substantially complete you can
see here that's one of the store
buildings that we'll be coming down and
won't be kept in the proposal and just
some more views of it and some openings
and now looking inside so as you can see
there is a lot of historic fabric that
does remain in the building
and it's proposed to obviously retain
much of that
so this is existing elevations of it of
the listed Barn so you can see it's
quite simple it is a freshing barn
and it has limited openings this is
existing ground floor plan and the
existing roof plan
um I'm not sure how well members will be
able to see this but this is a plan
which shows there are some areas of
building that will be demolished as part
of this um
uh proposal so it's this on the roof you
can see two rectangles here and there is
some ground floor bits that will also be
demolished and removed from the building
outlined in red here
so as it's been mentioned this building
is going to be split into two dwellings
so split a larger dwelling here and a
smaller dwelling here and split along
that line
as you have noted it's actually going to
have two floors and obviously it's a
large barn but there isn't a second
floor within the building at present
but it's not considered by officers that
that would be significantly harmful to
introduce that
first floor element to it and that's
just the roof plan of the proposed
building
so essentially what they're we're
looking the applicants are looking to do
for this listed building
would be to update the materials of the
building
um as you can see here there will be
Kent Peg tolls um introduced in Timber
weatherboarding and this is similar to
how the bomb would have existed
in historic times
the installation of doors and windows
are as you can see many more than we've
seen in the building as it currently
stands and they do give the building a a
residential feel
but it is considered that it is a way of
bringing the building back to life and
it would not be widely viewed from
outside the site
so you'd still get the appearance of the
bulk of the barn from looking outside
so that's just the other elevations
there the two end elevations of the
proposed
so I'm going to go to the upper unlisted
barn now
so again some photographs of it
and there's been an internal view of
part of the barn and another internal
View and this one does have a slight
um
a bit of a mezzanine or Upper Floor
inside it
again so this is the outline of the barn
as it exists
and the floor plans so as I say there is
a small element of first floor within
this Barn
and again there are going to be works
for Demolition and
bits that are going to be removed from
the barn to facilitate its conversion
again this will be converted to two
dwellings so you can see the proposed
plans here
and the elevations will be treated in a
similar way to the listed Barn
um it isn't a fairly poor condition at
the current time as has been mentioned
and again these will be Kent Peg tiles
the Timber weatherboarding and again you
will see there were a number of new
openings but again it is thought that
you would see the bulk of the building
from longer views are still being
of a scan form that you might expect to
see in the countryside
so moving on to the Cottages now
so that is an unlisted Barn just on the
edge there this is the Cottages
and some views of the cottages and how
they sit
and you note there are some extensions
that have been added to the Cottages so
this is the existing elevations
of the Cottages with their
um
extensions so this is the existing
ground floor of property
and you can see the existing first floor
here
and here you will see that the proposal
actually remove some exist the existing
additions to the cottage and actually
combines the two Cottages that exist at
the moment into a single dwelling
the extensions are to be removed are at
a later date to the original Cottage so
there is no objection to those going
there will be an actual additional
extension added to the cottage once
those new additions had been removed and
it becomes single dwelling as mentioned
and that's just the materials and the
elevations of those proposed at that
proposed unit and you'll see the sort of
theme of materials continues
on this unit as well
so now going to the Dutch Barn
so this is just some photographs of it
as you can see it's quite a large
building
and that's the inside of the Dutch Barn
to get a feel for what's going on in
there so again this is existing plans uh
the Dutch Barn so a ground floor plan
and this is the existing elevations
so and that's an actual section of the
barn but again you'll see here there's
going to be some demolition inside of
this uh the Dutch Barn
and it will again be split into two
units this one
will actually be
[Applause]
isn't a very poor state to repair and
it's going to be rebuilt but using the
existing frame and the footings that are
there will be retained
and as being mentioned again it will be
split into the two dwellings
and just a quick look at the storage
buildings that are the single story
units that run along the south of the
site they are fairly historic but not
unremarkable in appearance as you can
see but they do sort of set and you can
see the church be on there
and these again sorry that's the
existing plan of the storage buildings
again parts of it will be demolished in
turn leads to facilitate
the use this is existing elevations of
those storage buildings
and they will actually be put to use as
sort of
ancillary buildings to some of the plots
that back onto them so they were put to
things like as you can see here an
office or a cycle store but essentially
buildings
that would be used with the main
dwellings and but they will be retained
on site because they do have some
historic significance
so just a few images of how they would
look there so essentially
as I say we are looking at just the list
of building consent here
so we are looking at the impact of the
development on the actual grade two
listed Barn itself but also
the other bits that we've looked at
which we consider to be courteous listed
and the officer recommendation is
oh sorry to conclude we do accept there
will be some harm
to the listed buildings there will be
demolitions and new openings added to
buildings but we consider that harm is
outweighed by bringing the buildings
back into an active use
and yeah as has been mentioned reusing
existing buildings
um for a purpose going forwards so the
officer recommendation is to approve
thank you chair
I move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted with the vice chair please
second
Ed
thank you
um do I have any speakers yes I've got
counselor Moore at the back there first
thank you
yes thank you chair
um could miss Livingston just confirm we
use the word demolition
which is really quite negative
um would it not be read after real
adaptation is that not a more
um proactive word because it gives
everyone a negative sense just asking
the question
thank you
um I
I agree it creates a perception I think
there's a technical element
unfortunately that we we have to sort of
make it clear when someone is removing
part of the structure that it
constitutes demolition I mean it is one
of those things that in any Works to a
list of building when you're converting
it from a one use to a different use
there will be a change which will
probably result in the loss of some
fabric and so I appreciate whilst we're
saying there's harm in the sense of the
demolition
um but in this instance it's it's very
very notably outweighed by the fact that
it's bringing these buildings back into
use
thank you councilor Alban
thank you chair
um
personally I think it's a sympathetic
is sympathetic to the list of building
especially
um
and to retain all of the buildings and
to put them to good use is surely
something that we should support
as the officers have said there are some
issues in relation to it but
for my view
um it's I support the officer's
recommendation thank you chair
councilor uzeki
thank you chair yeah I agree with
Council Hartman there that it seems to
me that it's all very sympathetically
done it's bringing the buildings back
into use and they don't have an issue
with it at all thank you
councilor bayford
yeah yes me too um I think it's great to
see the buildings brought back into use
I think they've been done very
sensitively
um so nothing but
um agreement with the proposal thank you
councilor towning
thank you chap you know we we have a lot
of uh lovely old bars that are allowed
to just go to ruin uh and I mean I need
this opportunity here we should grab
hold of it and and encourage it and
encourage more of these sort of
developments there are a lot of bars in
the area I have seen someone have
actually totally completely destroyed so
I would encourage us to vote for the
approval thank you
Ghana
thank you yeah I just want to clarify
one thing I mean this here we're talking
about
we're not talking about approval for the
for the actual application the proposal
to what's going to be done to these
to these barns here are we this is this
is just for
for um
listed building consented some that
something can be done
I mean I'm here
so it's the physical works the listed
structures that are being approved in
terms of actually the next application
which is going for us that is
considering the use the standard of
accommodation you know issues to do with
well setting of listed buildings is one
thing that we considered in the planet
so and all the normal planning
considerations so it's a very specific
um set of of considerations on this one
um but it's the specific weighing up of
the changes the listed building still
has to consider whether or not it's the
sort of works that could facilitate a
use which we would um you know and those
Works themselves that we're considering
I mean yes so the buildings are in a
state
they're seriously at risk in a perilous
state of disrepair I mean they're
they're in that state because I've been
allowed to get into that estate
um you know that they if they had been
looked after
um over the years and not just left over
to vote they wouldn't be in that
perilous state of just wanted to make
that that point before we then go on to
talk about what we're actually going to
do to them thank you
and I have councilor Keene
thank you chair and I'm not sure if I'm
asking this in the right application or
not but it was just because the um
materials were mentioned for the roofs
and the the walls what about the windows
it's Timber windows and fenestration
proposed
councilor Moore
yes thank you dear just sort of
counterclaim what council Garner just
said
um it probably fell into disrepair
because the buildings no longer were
viable for usage and the cost to
actually keep them in the state was too
costly and so the listed buildings now
before us for redaptation to be reused
and continue going on so for that reason
there's a counter claim for everything
we've just said thank you
right thank you it sounds like we will
now move the moat to put the motion for
the officer's recommendation for
approval to the vote can I have all
those in favor please
and do I have any against
and any abstentions
thank you the motion is carried
for approval I'm conscious of it's very
warm and very tiring in here would
members like to take a five minute break
um we would just take five minutes and
then we'll move on to the the second
crumps Farm uh report thank you
all right everyone wants to carry on
that's that's fine no problem um we will
go on to
um uh item 5f cromps Farm
um and I have first speaking in favor of
the application I'm Susanna sanlon
please
firstly I'd like to um thank you for
your support on the design approach that
we've taken to the list of building
application we do welcome this and we
trust that you'll also support your
office's recommendation to on this
application also as planning concern on
this project I'm going to briefly
address the planning issues which
members have raised in calling this
application to committee hopefully this
will provide you with comfort that all
planning issues have been addressed to
the satisfaction of your offices which
is why the application has a
recommendation to defer and Delegate for
approval in accordance with the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development
regarding highway safety you will have
read in your papers that there are no
outstanding objections to this
application raised by KCC highways
offices are satisfied that following
revisions to provide a pedestrian
footprath along Short Lane and a section
106 contribution towards a possible 20
mile per hour Zone there will be no
highway safety concerns arising from
this development
in terms of traffic generation the
application demonstrates that the
proposed development will lead to fewer
trips and fewer large Vehicles than the
current equine use and therefore we hope
you will welcome these proposals
regarding ecology the biodiversity
officer initially asked for some
additional information which we duly
supplied upon receipt of this the
officer is now satisfied that there will
be no negative impacts on ecology
arising from this development
similarly in terms of impact on trees
the committee report confirms that
following the submission of amended
plans the council's agricultural
consultant has raised no objection to
the development therefore there are no
ecological or agricultural impacts which
would warrant a refusal
we are aware that some comments have
been raised in terms of the possible
impacts on community infrastructure The
Village has experienced wider
developments in recent years which are
not connected to this proposal and we
understand that these development
developments may have caused some
concern
however focusing on this application
alone which is actually only proposing
seven additional dwellings you will note
that your office is recommended
recommendation is that the application
should be judged on its own merits your
officer has advised that seven
additional dwellings are not considered
to result in significant harm to the
community infrastructure or facilities
and contributions are not required in
this instance
finally a note on drainage and flooding
whilst KCC had initially asked for some
additional information to be provided
prior to determination it has been
agreed that this detailed drainage work
would be more appropriately provided
post-determination and a relevant
condition is proposed
I agree with your counselor who
mentioned about the viability being key
to why we are proposing these dwellings
and whilst in equine use or even
agriculture use that have not been
sufficient funds to upkeep the buildings
and that's why at this point as is very
common with list of buildings and a
viable solution is being sought the
applications accompanied by a viability
assessment which is considered a range
of uses and this has been found the
application before you've been found to
be the minimum level of development
necessary to bring these buildings away
from risk and into a viable use so I
hope you'll support these applications
thank you speaking on behalf of Saint
Nicholas at Wade with SAR Parish Council
is councilor Dave divers
hello um as a village where we have and
our enduring over five years of
continual building work over
um four sites with four phases with
currently not one phase completed
um as we speak one of the we've got
three roads main roads into the village
one of them Manor Road is still full of
potholes unserviced and is inaccessible
for the disabled
though we sympathize to the plans
within the application we're only too
aware that once these plans are approved
the loan will be sold in variations will
be made
um therefore I would ask as a condition
of any consent being given the following
endorsement or conditions are included
in any approval
and this is through experience of what
us as a village are experiencing assets
egress to the site we would recommend
should be limited to the thanic way
Court Ray Road Route with no work
traffic permitted to enter or leave the
village by any other route
this bypasses hopefully most of the
listed buildings within the village and
avoiding the
narrowing of the road along the length
and of Mana road which is a described
and state that sin at the moment
no construction traffic should be
allowed to make deliveries or remove
waste during a school drop-off
collection times
mainly between 07450 900 and 1430 to
1545 access to this site for our Stuart
Lane is at a Crossroads where down
Barden Road and Court Road and the
street All Join which during those times
currently is a nightmare with school
drop-offs and it would just lead to
traffic chaos
we would also ask for all contractor
parking should be restricted to on-site
parking only
the game with Burgers experience of all
cars fans been parked all over the
village
we've lost their bond or retention of
funds should be in place to repair all
damage where to existing infrastructure
access to this site is right next to
grade one listed church the church
retaining wall and listed buildings
either side and we would ask that a
direct point of contact should be given
to the parish council in order that any
issues problems can be resolved in a
timely manner and at a local level level
we find if we can get contact with
somebody who can actually make decisions
then issues can resolve very quickly
um although there's been major
revisions to these plans but I was
understanding that some new builds were
also being
included we've only talked I think
raised at this meeting about repairs and
the of the listed buildings I need you
to start wrapping up please
um okay no new new builds have been
mentioned for your consideration but
those main points our experiences that
we can address those we should if it's
past we get a smoother thank you thank
you thank you
um so I will hand over to the principal
planning officer to outline the report
please
sorry thank you chair so again we have
the application site here outlined in
red
um and the blue land the church is here
and shuitt Lane running off over here
again we have the aerial photograph what
we've looked at previously I will skim
through some of the photographs and
things because we've seen them earlier
just now
um so that this is us at the actual
access to the site looking in
um you can see the Dutch barn and this
access will not change
um and that's looking up sure at Lane
so as I said this is existing site plan
the access that currently exists will
serve the development site
and again it will have some
alterations to allow for visibility and
to ensure that the Refuge vehicles and
things can enter and exit the site and
forward uh enter and exit the site but
it will be the same access with limited
alterations and we've mainly looked at
the buildings in the sort of Southern
half of the section
already but I'll just whiz through again
that's the listed Barn that we looked at
it's just a couple of photographs there
that's the unlisted Barn
these this is concierges that we talked
about which are being converted into a
single dwelling
this is a Dutch Barn Again
and lastly those are the single story
single story storage buildings that we
looked at
so again just to give an idea the
historic buildings are mainly focused
sort of to the south of the site but the
Dutch Barn sits here and these more
modern non-traditional buildings are
actually going to be removed from the
site and we'll look at the proposed site
plan going forward but as has been
mentioned
and in terms of the principle
development the site is in the
countryside but it is considered to be a
Brownfield site due to the nature of it
there being numerous buildings on site
and some hard surfacing and it's
Redevelopment it is supported by policy
SP 24 which is the countryside policy
so there is no objection in terms of the
principle of a development for this on
this site it is also noticed it is an
edge of Village site and we don't have
the five-year housing land Supply so
seven dwellings the net gain of seven
dwellings that will come from this
development will add to that housing
Supply albeit a small number of units
so
so I'm going to go through
um
the application kind of plot By plot
just get you a feel for some of the
plans that we haven't seen and as has
been mentioned there are actually two
new weddings being proposed as well as
conversions of the buildings so plot one
is the first of the new builds
so this is It's a single dwelling as you
can see here
it's traditional in design and it will
have similar materials to those that are
being used that were found on the
um existing buildings within the site
and are being used to repair those
buildings so it's a traditional form and
something that you would expect to sort
of find
in the countryside so plots two and
three are actually formed by the Dutch
Barn that we've already seen so if I'll
Whispering these plans a little so
that's existing floor plan existing
elevations and these are the proposed
floor plans so it's split down the
middle here
so this is the ground floor plan
and then we have the bed the first floor
plan and the roof plan here
and so you can see the elevation again
as it proposed
um here with plots two and three
um plot four is the upper additional
building the new build that's being
proposed and this is built as you can
see here as a sort of new Dutch Barn
essentially
um so it will replicate to some extent
but be smaller the one that's next door
so it's a single unit again so you can
see it sits there it's ground floor it's
fairly open plan there and a number of
bedrooms up there but as I say it will
be built to look like a Dutch Barn so it
wouldn't be something unexpected sort of
in the countryside
so turning to plot five that's actually
the Cottages that we looked at
previously
as you've seen at the moment it's a been
subdivided into two dwellings which have
extensions either side
those
um extensions as we mentioned previously
are to be demolished and that's just the
existing
elevations of it so it becomes a single
dwelling
and but it with a new extension in this
location here
and just to well we've already looked at
the elevations but it's fairly
traditional in design and the materials
are similar to those that can be found
Elsewhere on this side and within Saint
Nicholas at Wade as a whole
so
now looking at plots um six and seven
they will be formed from the unlisted
barn and again we've looked at this
previously so whiz kind of through them
so that's existing floor plans the
existing elevations
and this is the proposed elevation so
plot six and seven would be formed like
that and again the materials are kempeg
tiles Timber windows
um
a Timber fenestration
and they're the floor plan so you can
see that's plot seven is the larger of
the units and plot six there so that's
the ground floor and plot
um
the first floor plot six there and plot
seven the larger unit there
and that's just the roof plan
so turning to plots eight and nine
they are on
of the proposed plans here so they will
be
in this sorry that's the proposed ground
floor plan of it the proposed first
floor plan again two units
um this is the elevations of those two
units so again fairly traditional but
they will form inside the side to look
like residential dwellings but from a
wider view would look more like
um
a barn or a Countryside building that
you might expect to find on a farm or of
that site and then you've got the two
end elevations here
so
again just having a quick look at the
storage buildings which you've already
seen they're the existing plans existing
elevations and as mentioned they will
form part of the curtainage with plot
seven eight and nine to provide
outbuildings essentially
um for that for those units
so to give you a sort of overview of the
application
as I said the majority of the build of
the application does reuse existing
buildings
so the only two new units are plots one
and plot four
and you will also see that
some of the more modern units disappear
from the site and are demolished and
they are not historic in nature so
that's welcomed
excuse me
um
so it is considered there will be quite
a significant amount of open space
created by the removal of those more
modern units and the storage buildings
that were in between some of the the
listed Barn I'm sorry the Lister barn
and the unlisted Barn in the cottage
and there will be Landscaping
Etc
around the edges of the site which help
create a buffer zone and that transition
into the more open Countryside that's
beyond
um in terms of trees there are some
pockets of trees on the site at the
present time and some soft Landscaping
but the site has become a little bit
overgrown in
the recent history so this application
does seek to remedy that and obviously
create more formal planting to some
extent around the edges of the garden
but also so add some additional trees
here
the southern half of the site so
essentially this bit
here is within the Conservation Area
the northern part is not
but there are no tree protection
orders or any
thing like that up on any part of the
site
so the blue lines dotted lines that you
can see are actually trees that will be
removed and there are some of those but
a tree report has been submitted and has
been reviewed by our agriculture advisor
and no objection is raised to the loss
of those trees
foreign
excuse me and also you can see here that
has been mentioned there's a number of
new trees and shrubs and things being
planted it's all these green circles
with those sort of
crosses around so they will be around
the edges of the site here and here and
some in this location here
so we do consider as officers that there
will be sufficient planting to soften
the development and to bring it as I say
into that transition from a residential
thing into
the surrounding more open Countryside
in terms of the living conditions
they're given the distances involved and
relationships with surrounding
residential development is not
considered that there would be any
adverse impacts on the joining occupiers
and the scheme has been developed to
avoid any sort of mutual overlooking or
loss of light or anything like that from
between
the development that's actually proposed
on site
the existing access as I mentioned would
be used to serve the development again
so that would remain essentially as
uh shown
um we've had tracking diagrams to show
that the
development can accommodate a 13 meter
refuse truck and a fire tender and they
can maneuver around and end into an X
exit in first gear
in forward Gill sorry
um in terms of parking you can see that
most of the units have at least two
parking spaces and some of the larger
the larger units have free parking
spaces and that is sufficient considered
sufficient to serve the development
um
there is also
a foot way which I might be slightly
difficult to see but it's where the
letter is and it runs sort of from the
church up to the sort of access to the
site
is a public footpath which is the
applicants would provide and that isn't
considered to help with
um pedestrian safety along that stretch
of the
um
student loan where there is no footpath
currently
and the applicants have also agreed to
provide fifteen thousand pound to KCC
and that is to be put towards
um the creation of a 20 mile an hour
speed limit within the village
this contribution has not yet actually
been secured formally in terms of
illegal agreement
so that that's the reason why excuse me
the application is going to be deferred
to allow this to be submitted if members
were to agree with the principle of the
development
um as has been mentioned initially KCC
ecology did have cons some concerns
about the information that was submitted
um in terms of supporting information in
terms of ecology particularly in
relation to barn owls and reptiles so
additional work and reports and surveys
were carried out by the applicants no
reptiles were found on the site so it
was accepted that no mitigation was
needed for those
there was also no suitable nesting
location for barn owls but it was found
that there were some pellets so there
might be a roosting site somewhere or be
used by bar Nails occasionally but
um KCC ecology are now satisfied with
the studies that have come forward and
they have suggested a number of
conditions that have been agreed by the
applicants in relation to ecology
um so I mean I can clarify those if
members need that but they are set out
in the list of conditions
in terms of drainage it as has been
mentioned KCC Suds did require or would
have preferred some information to come
forward
and be prior to the termination of the
application but given that the
application is located in flood zone one
which has the least
um
danger of flooding and that most of the
development will be taking place either
on sites that are already have
structures on and they're just being
converted or
sites that had upper development on it
is considered that is satisfactory to
condition that information to come
forward and it's not required to be
dealt with prior to the determination of
the application
so to Inc to conclude sorry the council
has no five-year housing land Supply as
mentioned and the development would
bring a net gain of seven new dwellings
to the housing market
the housing Supply and it is a
Brownfield site so it is acceptable for
development in in terms of our policy SP
24.
the existing buildings
um well us would bring so
some of the list some of the buildings
on site as we've discussed previously
are listed or
of his age and
um
of an age to be considered cartilage
listed and they will bring be brought
back into an active use with by this
development and so we consider that as a
major benefit to this proposal
and there would be no harm to the living
conditions of neighboring occupiers
biodiversity drainage or highway safety
and in terms of
um what has been mentioned by the parish
council there is an opportunity and a
condition indeed imposed for a
construction management plan which could
secure things like hours of deliveries
and hours of constructions and things
like that so we consider that could be
enforce for that condition
to avoid the the negative impacts of
General Construction
we also have agreement and indeed a a
legal agreement for the spa Sam
contribution has already been received
and as mentioned the reason why we're
defer asking for the application to be
deferred back to officers is to secure
that contribution to KCC for the towards
the speed limit
reduction throughout the village so it
is a recommendation to defer and
delegate back to offices for that thank
you chair
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation to defer and delegate is
approved with the vice chair please
second seconded and all those in
right
we just did bait that would have been
really quick wouldn't it you see this is
why I wanted a break because I'm getting
tired it's too hot in here okay do I
have any speakers I've actually got
Council on bayford first
thank you chair
um I feel that this application
represents most considerate
Redevelopment and I think some other
members are in agreement I very much
welcome this seven additional very well
designed dwellings and the landscaping
and I'm very happy to support this
application thank you
thank you anyone else
councilor Garner
thank you yeah um yeah it does sound
good having seven additional dwellings
um added
for the district I'm not quite sure we
should celebrate that much they're not
exactly the the highest priority type
dwellings that the residents of thanet
uh of the choir but um it is a very
nicely laid out
um
plot and and buildings or proposed
buildings I have a lot of sympathy for
counselor divers
for what he said and for I have a lot of
sympathy for Saint Nicholas at Wade as a
whole because the times I visit there it
almost seems like it is under siege
every corner of the village there are
large developments taking place none of
which seem to be progressing at a great
Pace but do make the The Village
um messy untidy and
um has said some of the roads are pretty
dangerous to navigate sometimes I think
it really is important that
the con the considerations that were
asked for are considered and included in
the construction management plan
um around times of contractor deliveries
and
um access to site down those roads and
we should certainly
um it we should certainly be making sure
that the the neighboring Church which
has been there since the 11th century I
believe
um remains is secured and doesn't get
damaged at all or isn't put at any risk
one thing I did quite like the sound of
um was the contribution to KCC to enable
a 20 mile per hour speed limit to be
implemented within the village and I
would certainly encourage
planning officers when talking to other
large applicants for large developments
to um
consider asking for that in other parts
of thanet certainly welcome it in
broadstairs and super peers if
developers were willing to put up that
sort of money to make the streets of
than it safer thank you
I'll um I've just come back on the um
the construction management plan Point
um so in terms of the the list of things
that that Council divers has mentioned
um you know we absolutely understand and
we know the issues that have been
created in Nicholas indeed we serve two
breach condition notices on the
different relevance one and the length
and one on Manor Road because of uh
contractors parking not on the site
um and
um so we will definitely get that
considered within the construction
management plan condition which is I
think conditions seven
um in the um in the application the one
thing that we wouldn't be able to do
through that condition and and wouldn't
be justified as a planning condition is
the creation of a bond the issue with
the damage that could occur
um in terms of to structures either side
that is something that obviously would
be a matter for civil recourse if for
example something was damaged as part of
construction
it was certainly though take care in
terms of what we approve in the
construction management plan for example
where the parking occurs on the site to
try and avoid any issues that could
obviously occur so and we will review
the the recording of this meeting as I
say when discharging uh or looking to
discharge that condition and obviously
the you know the app the applicants are
present at this meeting so I'm sure
that's that's understood if it's pursued
by by those that have put in the
application thank you
councilor bright
chair
um yeah I I really like the development
I'm I totally approve of the fact that
the materials are being retained
um I also wanted to say that um
um I think that councilor divers
requests are very reasonable especially
with regard to highway safety
um at school drop-off times
um and
um just a sort of question about the
condition the 20 mile per hour speed
risk restriction and trying to secure
the fifteen thousand pounds
um
what happens if you don't secure that I
mean is that a guarantee thank you
um so it'll be it's a it's a unilateral
undertaking in fact we've got a draft of
it at the moment or we're trying to work
through to finalize that so the the
issue here is that it's it's for KCC to
then make a traffic regulation order
under the highway act so what would then
happen is there is is subject to public
consultation so it's it's that the
applicant is providing the money for
that process to run through it and run
its course and hopefully because this
has been something that's been mentioned
by people that have written in it can be
something that's supported by the
village but obviously it does need an
assessment of a number of different
roads
um effectively if the development were
to start and that money hadn't been paid
they would breach their unilateral
undertaking and then we would look at
um well first of all we would obviously
try and secure that money if it didn't
transpire it was being provided then we
would move to more
um uh I could put it while prosecution
and potentially you know injunction type
issues to do with enforcement don't
entertain like that to be an issue this
is a relatively low amount of money in
comparison to developments of this scale
and obviously being that the viability
is something that's been part of this
different we do things reasonable and we
do think we can secure it
do I have counsel them all
yes thank you chair
um I'm I'm fully in support of what's
going on in this development
um it's sad to see that some trees are
having to be removed and I understand
that because there's no tpos but there's
any guarantees for for the trees that
are being planted to be mature trees or
is it just going to be the small spindly
ones that we get
um if I come back on that so whilst you
can see on this plan it includes some
some species that are shown as as a list
of species there is still a condition
which is condition four which would
actually require the details to come in
there's also condition six which is the
Landscape Management plan and we know
that this is an issue that members raise
pretty much every every month a planning
committee and it's something that we've
been much more conscious of when
um trying to work with developments that
have actually started on site at the
moment and looking to ensure compliance
and there is a you know a monthly
meeting which tries to bring together
all the elements of the process from
enforcement conditions are um our
planning system who deals with trees as
well as case officers to identify when
sites have started visiting those sites
immediately and making sure that they've
been planted in accordance with the
Landscaping that we've already agreed so
it's something that we we are keeping I
suppose a closer eye on because we've
now got you know we've got the resources
to be able to do that and and the sort
of process successes in place so we are
confident that we'll be able to secure
these changes but we don't have quite
the level of detail yet that's why the
condition is on there
interface just one point picking up from
cancer Moore
your condition six the immunity area
should be managed in accordance with the
approved Landscaping management plan in
perpetuity
so that would presumably mean that
anybody wanting to make any alterations
that would impinge on the amenity area
would be automatically refused
um so if a planning application came in
that for example looked to
um well you see the D on that plan that
look to put some dwellings on that site
so hypothetically obviously there is a
rationale behind us having it as a
landscaped area and therefore you know
there would be a resultant harm to both
I suppose the character of this
development but also the area as well as
the loss of of trees and which in
themselves in effect there is a
character point there which is covered
under qdo2 so we would have to consider
the merits the case it's not an
automatic you know rubber stamp refusal
but at the same time the condition
points towards the reason why we're
getting it and then that would then
transpire us to you know a likely
opposition in the application
okay any more questions or speakers in
that case I will now put the motion for
the office's recommendation to defer and
delegate to the votes those in favor
only
and those against
and any abstentions
thank you that's carried to defer and
delegate
that concludes the public speaking for
this meeting I will now call upon the
clerk to remove read out the remaining
planning applications if any member
wishes to reserve an application will
they please call out as the clerk reads
thank you chair
so we have a01 land north of Telegraph
Hill industrial estate lawn Tree Road
Ramsgate
we have ao2 Mount Pleasant Lorry Park
tuffield Street Ramsgate
we have ao4 peer head shelter the harbor
broadstairs
and we have d07 land to the north of
Fairlawn Road and West of Northwood Road
broadstairs
yesterday got one
okay thank you
um can we just pause for a few minutes
to allow councilor Michaelson to return
before we um go on to that one
okay
um
can I have a proposer to move that the
applications that have not been reserved
be determined in accordance with the
officer's recommendations
a council organ proposer do I have a
second uh councilor ezeki do members
agree
thank you and I will just for the
benefit of the public call upon the
clock to read out the applications that
have not been determined and then we'll
move on to the one that these ones have
been sorry that have been determined
we're getting there
thank you chair the applications that
have been determined are a01 land north
of Telegraph Hill industrial estate
laundry Road Ramsgate
ao2 Mount Pleasant Lorry Park tuffield
Street Ramsgate
and ao4 peer hedge sorry peer head
shelter the harbor broadstairs thank you
thank you and so we now move on to the
one that has been reserved do7 and I
will ask the principal planning officer
to outline Blaze
thank you chair this is application site
here
um there's been a number of applications
on this site previously and that members
may or may not have um participated in
the discussions for
um this is Fair Lawn Road
um leading to the application site here
and to the right is Northwood Road
and then this is an aerial view of the
site which is in this location and then
another view here
um showing and the site so the the road
um is a cul-de-sac it contains a number
of semi-detached properties all of a
similar design
um you could see the the boundary
treatment that runs around the extent of
the site in this location here there's
currently an application pending for the
land to the north of the site as well
so this is the site in this location
here so it's an allocated housing site
as you can see it forms part of a wider
site within the local plan for um for
housing
and then this are some views from the
road looking at the site so um this is
uh the site in this location here so
this uh um this was originally a fenced
off area but this has been removed and
the access created
um previous application has been
approved for the development of site for
six houses which I'll show you the plan
for later this is now inside the site
and you can see the boundary of the site
is the fence in this location here
and then this is the center of the site
again the the boundaries is sort of
approximately here and then this is the
left hand side of the site with the
boundary and the backs onto the
commercial of the Town Center in this
location here
and then this is just inside Fairlawn um
Road looking at the existing properties
you can see um this neighbor property
extends up to the boundary and has a
two-story side extension and then again
views just showing the design
um and scale of the properties in Fair
Lawn again this is the other side
there's a substation behind this
Hedgerow here and then there's again the
Sim the same style properties running on
the road and again the application site
in the distance here and then further
along here so this is a privacy approved
plan
um that members has historically seen
this was approved for six houses on the
site
with two pairs of semi-detached and two
detached units
um it's since come to light that there's
a covenant on the land which means that
this development can't be brought
forward and the Covenant restricts a
number of units on the site so the
application was submitted for four
houses this was the original submission
so it's for a large detached house on
the left hand side here and then for
three Terrace houses on the right again
linked to the Covenant so the actual
layout of the dwellings can't be
provided in the way it was previously
provided with following the front
building lines of both existing
properties in the road the Covenant
restricts it so that the development can
only happen set back on the site and one
unit on the left here so it was a bit of
a strange strange Covenant but one that
does result in sort of a restriction on
the way in which we can um design the
way the development's been designed and
laid out so this was the original
submission concerns were raised with
this
um in the fact it was it felt like it
was completely out of character with the
area in terms of the properties along
this road with this property projecting
further forward and not following any of
the building lines and there was
concerns with the properties on the
right hand side which were all three
store not three stories away three
two-story properties and there was
concerns with the potential of
overlooking of the neighboring
properties from the windows and also
again just being out of keeping with the
pattern and development so an amended
plan has been submitted which is is this
plan so this is what's being considered
tonight the number of units has been
reduced there's now three units on the
site so a detached four bed unit on the
left here and then two detached two bed
units a two yeah bed units on the right
hand side right here which are basically
Bungalow units with accommodation within
the roof space
um the the road
um continues to wrap around again linked
to this the Covenant but then does
provide parking three of those spaces
would be visitor parking spaces which
could be utilized by other residents in
the road each of these units are
provided with two parking spaces and
then you can see there's a large
driveway here with a garage a detached
garage in this location
here
and so this is a design of the larger
detached unit so it's been designed to
almost have the appearance of a pair of
the semi-detached units so they can keep
staying keeping with the character of
the road so it's not completely
um following the the fenestration that
you can see in the existing properties
but it's quite close to it it's similar
in scale follows the same ease level and
a similar Ridge height and as you can
see yeah just basically tries to give
the impression of a pair of semi so that
it fits in with with the street and then
this is a rear elevation with feed
access and some solar panels and then
some side view so one of the concerns
from residents because there's been a
few objections from residents on this
was to do with a first of all Terrace
that was originally proposed that would
have overlooked neighbors that's gone
side windows are now all proposed to be
obscure glazed so that will prevent any
overlooking of neighboring properties
um and then again this is the other side
elevation so again an obscure based
Windows here in place of any any
balconies this is the ground floor of
the property
and this is the first floor level so
whilst the bedroom windows on this on
the side
um would be a skew glaze they've also
got rear and front facing Windows as
well so there's plenty of light and
Outlet to those rooms
and then the roof plan this is the
garage elevation
which as you saw was set back on the
site and there was landscaping around it
which would help to screen it this is
one of the Bungalow units so it does
have a slightly raised ease level and to
achieve the accommodation roof spec in
the roof space
um but the much more modest inside and
scale now so whilst they're set back
because of the reduction in in scale of
the units it's felt it's it's something
that could be considered more
appropriate and and not as dominant
within the street and something that
would actually work in in the area and
you can see a mix of materials with
Timber cladding brickwork metal windows
and then these are the side elevations
so there's now there's no first floor
side facing windows to the neighbors and
as you saw from this there's no first
floor front windows either so there's
now no no potential overlooking of
neighboring properties from this
and then this is the um other side
elevation and that's the rear elevation
and then this is just the floor plan of
those Bungalow units and then you can
see at first of all levels just the two
bedrooms and with the windows internally
facing towards their garden areas
and then the refund so you can just see
the street elevations here so this
bottom one is showing the detached unit
and showing how it's similar in scale in
terms of Ridge and ease as the existing
properties but there's a bit more space
in between the unit so whilst it's
slightly different and it's at the end
of the road so it can work to be
slightly different to the other
properties
and then this is the Bungalow units that
are now set back so again you can see
those in relation to the two-story
um much smaller inch scale than the
original
proposal and then just another view
there which is showing the garage in
that location and then again the two
bungalows in relation to the neighbors
so
um
given the fact it's a allocated housing
site the principle is acceptable
um there's no concerns regarding the
actual design following these amendments
it's felt like it's in keeping the
character of the area and the pattern
development
Landscaping is proposed as you can see
in this location here which would wrap
around the parking help to screen this
and around the boundaries here and KCC
ecology raised concerns with the loss of
a mature hedge along the southern
boundary the applicants agree to retain
that that's now within a condition for
the Landscaping to show that hedge
retained there's new Hedgerow planting
along the northern boundary these trees
in this location are outside the site
that would be retained and there's a
condition to make sure there's no impact
on any trees during construction works
um KCC highways have raised no concerns
with it the parking is considered
acceptable there's adequate parking for
this detection unit and the other units
and as I mentioned there's now the visit
parking spaces as well
um in terms of uh Refuge lawyers they
currently reverse into the road and they
would continue to do that so
um race for these units would have to be
provided on the pavement area close to
the end of this road so that would just
be collected as it currently is within
the road
um fire engines wouldn't be able to turn
within this space because the turning
head isn't large enough so the
applicants agree to a sprinkler system
within the units to make sure there's no
concerns and fire safety
um
and in terms of the impacts on neighbors
as well permissive development rights
for these two smaller units has been
removed to make sure there's no future
impact on on the neighbors from any
future development as well
so and the application is recommended
for a defer for approval subject to the
submission of the unilateral undertaking
to secure the special protection area
contribution and thank you
thank you
um move that the officer's
recommendation for deferral is approved
with the vice chair please second
seconded
and do I have any questions or comments
counselor Ghana
yeah I thought since I asked it to be
discussed I thought
I've upset a few people but yeah I mean
yes this is so this is the third time
it's been before the planning committee
um well I will start off by saying
positive some positive things I mean
there are positive changes to this that
um that are welcomed
um but I did there is things that I
really did want to clarify about this
when we approved the original planning
application
for um
to build for six dwellings on here there
wasn't access to the site
for I think it was assumed that access
to the site for construction would would
not be from Fair Lawn Road it would be
from an entrance off of North Wood Road
through the through the adjacent site
which is as you say there's a planning
application for
um
uh to get access to this it then turned
out that they they couldn't access
couldn't be got via Northwood Road so
some of the concerns of the what one or
two of us addressed were realized in the
Fairlawn Road then had to become the
access to the site so that's why it came
back here for the second time and we
agreed A variation of condition eight to
the original application for six
dwellings now it turns out this third
application is being made because the
original one for six dwellings couldn't
be delivered because for Covenant
on the land which which one of my
questions will be could you give us a
few more details about that Covenant and
why that is um that is having this
impact on it but I will say that if we
and it is like likely to be approved but
if we approve this application
is the access
to the site assumed to be up Fair Lawn
Road is there a provision in this
application for Access up Fair Lawn Road
that there wasn't in the original six
one for six dwellings
and can I have some ashore or can we
have some assurances
that within the construction management
plan
that is one of the conditions here that
there won't that road that fell on road
is pretty congested anyway
the construction workers and
construction workers Vehicles won't be
able to park won't be allowed to park on
that road they will have to part off
a road some way away so that they don't
cause further congestion for residents
who live in Fair Lawn Road and the road
that fell on road goes off of so there's
a couple of things there could you could
you explain a little bit more about the
Covenant and why it's had this impact
and then something about access to the
site for construction traffic and will
construction
workers Vehicles not be allowed to park
in Fairlawn Road and there there is one
other thing here that there is so there
is this other application on the larger
site
adjacent to this that obviously we're
not here to consider
but is there anything in this
application that would stop that road
which currently would be a dead end and
a turnaround becoming a through road
because the application next to it is
for much many more I think 50 or 60
houses and if this Fairlawn Road was to
become an access road to the site next
to it then that would become even more
a nightmare for residents of Fairlawn
Road to go from having a cul-de-sac to
now
traffic from for 50 odd houses going up
and down their Road
thank you
um so in terms of their Covenant I
haven't seen the exact wording of the
Covenant it's not a material
consideration for planning but from what
I understand
um the owner the previous owner of the
site when said in the land to the
current owner and put something in
um the
um the the agreement for it with this
Covenant that basically restricted the
number of units that they could have on
the site and also where they could go on
the site so from what I understand they
could only have a single unit in this
location and they could only have
units that were set back on the site so
that that's the basic of what I
understand of this Covenant it's not for
us to consider all we can consider is
whether this plan before us is is
acceptable
um in terms of the character of the area
and and the other considerations
um in terms of the construction
management plan
um we there's no plans to have this go
back to having construction from
Northwood Road so the construction would
be from Fairland Road
um we previously did approve that with
that variation and condition application
um obviously there were lots of concerns
from roses about it so we made sure we
had quite um a strong construction
management plan with the previous
application and we had it submitted
prior to the determination so we would
look to try and make sure we had
um similar requirements through any new
construction management plan for this
site and obviously a benefit with this
one is that because there's fewer units
there's a lot more space on site for the
parking for construction vehicles
um whereas before with the the six units
it was quite tight and we were you were
restricted to this Central space for and
this area in the far right where the
parking originally was now we've got
this whole area here that whilst
constructing these units this area here
could be used for deliveries and and
construction vehicles so there should be
less of an impact now on on residents
not the actual build time as well should
be less because there's few units as
well so it should be better than the
previous scheme in terms of the impact
on Neighbors from construction works
um and then the final point you said
about um the access so the development
to the north
um again that will be coming before
members um because it's been called in
um we don't have the final plans for
this one yet but the plans that we're
currently looking at are showing
um residential units backing on to this
Northern boundary of this site so it's
not showing any vehicular access it
would continue through onto this
vehicular access it will just all be
backed on to buy Residential Properties
um with approved application we did look
at trying to get a pedestrian link from
this um from Fair Lawn Road in through
the site and there was a condition that
we did have on there originally to try
and secure that
but it it's I think residents again are
concerned with that from from Fairland
Road and I've seen that in in responses
from from them about having a pedestrian
connection and at the moment with the
scheme above it's difficult to actually
achieve that connection because of the
the houses backing onto onto the area so
at the moment there's no plans for any
form of link from Fairlawn Road to the
to the northern development
okay Council open
yeah very very quickly chair
um the principal of development has been
has been agreed it's there it's
nice to see actually it's a nice
development it's nice to see the
inclusion of solar panels and the
sprinkler systems I I actually think is
that that's something that under our
local plan we need to get done to ensure
that every new development has solar
panels fitted and I think that's
something that we should be doing and I
fully support this application thank you
thank you any other speakers in that
case can we move the motion to the vote
all those in favor
and
yes
any against
and any abstentions
nope
thank you very much
um so that has been
approved for deferral and that concludes
the business for this meeting thank
everyone for their attendance and good
night